hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry I'm
Veronica
so we three just came back from watching
the hateful eight where Arclight did not
refund my money what they did instead
was they gave me a readmission that I
could use online because I was 15
minutes past the hour mark when what
they can return money to me how
unfortunate well they wouldn't return me
my money
what experience was this for the hateful
eight today there was one ticket extra
that I had to return because Oh
beforehand really because you came
looking with no-one Jerry I'm sorry
we're supposed to bring a date this was
a romantic film that we just came back
from yeah awkward it is just you there
dude anyway none of that's true we're
again we're gonna talk about the hateful
eight spoiler talk here it's more gonna
be a talk I don't want to feel like
we're reviewing you know what and there
are like there are only spoilers for
this movie if you're like a Tarantino
fan like I don't know very many people
were looking oh don't say anything
people eat guys like it's not like Star
Wars I feel like you can't though like
you can spoil things but like people
aren't freaking out about it unless
they're Tarantino fan I feel like the
most you can give away is the plot and
like descriptions of the character sure
who dies and and what whose allegiances
are where and who people actually
otherwise there's lots of stuff to spoil
but yeah um but immediately talking
about this film I really liked I really
liked it you know like there's it has
the we saw it on 70-millimeter where
there's the huh yeah we saw it on
70-millimeter
where you know like the film and I like
that touch the touch of that was really
nice well it's really good like the you
know there's lots of definition it's
weird like it's weird seeing 70 I I wish
they hadn't edged it out of the dome cuz
like I said my master in the dome and
they shot that on 70 millimeter too and
that was like yeah so like to see it on
it on a screen that's way big you know I
don't know if I don't know if they're
playing it on like an IMAX style screen
but but
to see our really big screen you get an
even better sense but even on this
screen it's like you can tell the detail
the definition that film grain yeah I
was so it did look very old-fashioned
like a real movie that grainy
yeah like the the grain look is always
cool to add you know it's like this it
makes the you know landscape sinister
before I've noticed it more when it was
landscape shots yeah much easier to
notice yeah much easier to know that you
were really pretty by the way
opening was very pretty it's funny how
like the two Christmas movies like the
big talked about Christmas films were
the revenant in April 8th and they're
both like take places the snow yeah last
time anybody release like a nice movie
on Christmas because because people
release Christmas movies like a month
before time so that everyone can see
them ten times with their kids yeah you
know but okay so in this movie just
starting off like from the very
beginning I love how this film really
honors the title in the sense of these
characters are not the most likeable in
a lot of ways like even with Kurt
Russell Kurt Russell to me is the least
bad out of everyone yeah he's really
he's not very likable but but pound for
pound at least would they give you to
work with in terms of his backstory he
doesn't seem like a completely terrible
guy he seems like he keeps to some
integrity and certain like principles he
decides to live by he's got a coat he's
a dick but he has a cup yeah he's a
solid like his sorry what when he hits
her in the face several times like that
is really really yeah and that that
immediately makes him not so likable to
because even though we don't even though
we're like hearing cuz was there
anything specific they said that she
actually did yeah murderer of some sort
we don't know the the intimate details
yeah like it seemed like she would be
like the nasty kind of murderer
why lion stabbed a guy to death or push
his eyeballs in or some [ __ ] you know
and I mean you know here here be
spoilers but but you know I mean she's
part of this gang yeah so we can only
assume that it has something to do with
that as well especially for it a $10,000
bounty I think she played that very very
well like just her facial expressions in
the nasty oh she's just so nasty no it
wasn't likable at the same time yeah
until they if she's a great like you you
spend so much of this movie being like
what is her deal like what she's making
all like she's the whole time you get
the sense that she knows something or
she's got something just going on in her
head and you're like what is it and then
when it comes out you're like yeah well
done yeah she she is some something else
and have [ __ ] a movie man yeah like
jeez I love the makeup on her like the
nasty teeth like she's one of the very
like cuz you get like other characters
way later past the intermission where
it's like you get a sneak peek at some
characters like Zoe Bell was the people
who run that place oh yeah Minnie and
was named sweet sweet days sweet Dave
yeah and their little stab thing they're
the only good people you know you start
to in a Tarantino universe especially
this University start to wonder this
world I should say you start to wonder
how good anybody is but but you can
assume these people are probably all
right yeah yeah Vinnie is probably an
okay gal she seems nice enough
what I love about Tarantino's approach
to this film was that it's such a build
up film that the like there's violence
here and there like when Kurt Russell
[ __ ] like elbows Daisy like that was
a nasty elbow you know and there's
always the grittiness to it well it's
not cool like it it has an impact and it
still has rhythm but it's not cool you
are cringing each time yeah something
violent happens through most of this
yeah and it's like everyone's wielding
guns and stuff and talking about they
like the hangman
here in their backstories and stuff that
it it's it's a build-up to see like to
take a look into their world you know
it's it's brilliant in that way well it
incorporates that sense of like let you
know like legends that would that would
sort of crawl across the Old West you
know and and ya know people who would
get reputations and they would get
nicknames and you know these things have
you know a bunch of people some of who
have reputations that precede them you
know coming together in people's
perception sort of like social media
back in the day yeah you didn't know
stuff people would know you know yeah
and the the film to like humors really I
don't know what's the work for it again
subjective you know like I'm not I
didn't really laugh a lot during this
film but I noticed like especially in
the first half a lot of people were lap
I know you were laughing I was laughing
my ass off I was surprised by how no I
heard people were like cracking up like
before i watch the film i heard that
people would just dive laughter with
this film and i could see why they would
I don't think it's a gutbuster but
there's a lot of humor throughout I mean
because it's it's that thing of like
when people are being Despicable but the
movies not trying to convince you
they're not and that's just what those
characters would say you're just like oh
yeah that's terrible but I'm laughing at
it you know sorry what's up this is kind
of are you in the same topic
sure there's a podcast baby cutting any
of them right this isn't a video um I
want to backtrack a little bit with Kurt
Russell's character and Daisy what was
Kurt Russell's character it's named the
hangman John Ruth anyway well they're as
weird as it sounds I I kind of liked
their chemistry like their circumstances
and like he treated her like [ __ ] but
there still seemed to be some kind of
like understanding between yeah yeah
there was something there where at times
it kind of look like her Russell might
have even liked her in some ways you
never cared about respect that
feistiness cuz that's the thing is like
it's horrible as he is to her some of
the time it's like you get the sense
that they're both kind
clashing the whole time like she gives
him a run for his money in a way like
yeah you know I mean she's still his
prisoner but you get the sense that
she's not broken by him in any way you
know and I mean if you think about it
they've probably been chained to each
other for I don't know it may be a few
days yeah
so that's a lot of time to be spending
with person it takes a while you can see
that time that they spent just enough
you know in the movies I like I like the
like the beginning a lot of the
character you know the more I just think
about this film the more I actually like
it you're kind of do not a lot yeah it's
an impacted movie and people will
usually expect a instant opinion out of
me you would like the first half I
remember when it cut to intermission I
was like really don't know how I feel
about this movie now well now when I
look back on it you're not supposed it's
not completely yeah yeah yeah yeah and
it's cool to do that because like we
said earlier it gets a debate going
already halfway through the film yeah
because it does play out like clue where
it's a mystery you're trying to I do
have a question though
how did Kurt Russell catch on to the
fact that there were that there might be
someone who's you know like trying to
rescue Daisy or something um that didn't
make sense to me how we caught on to I
feel like it could have originally
started as paranoia yeah something
somebody even says that I think out loud
I think yeah but I don't know like where
that actually came from but besides that
like that is like the big plot of the
film essentially well I think it's
because ladies he already missed rut or
doesn't trust Walton Goggins you know
and then you got other people in this in
this Shack that are sort of colorful and
questionable and everybody's got ties to
Red Rock you know right and I'm sure he
realized that she was a part of the gang
so she's got a gang probably going to
try to help her out true cuz it's like
you know how what a coincidence that I
will wind up here with the future
sheriff and the hangman yeah so
something must be happening here yeah
yeah at least
could be you know and I'm glad Tarantino
made the choice of not putting Django in
it and instead rewriting it and then
putting Sam Jackson in there yeah is
that character it belongs way more with
the hateful eight for sure oh yeah oh
he's in Kurt Russell and Sam Jackson
learn their dialogue when they're
writing together is great like you know
I like how they're like don't I know you
yeah we had steak once oh yeah we met
eight months ago and you might be more
inclined to remember somebody you only
met once eight months ago because you
know life is different then and yeah and
what I like too is like it's not a big
plot point but you do get a sense for
like the first couple chapters of the
movie are all in that stagecoach and
you're like yeah everything took a long
time back then like this is a long
journey and all we got to do is talk
like we'd have more reason to discuss
who we are and you know what's going on
around us yeah exactly and I like how
Kurt Russell's you know interaction with
Daisy wasn't just like just be quiet you
know don't talk like there are times
where he let her just be her you know
like it wasn't always but they weren't I
like that there was a good moment where
he lets her play the guitar until until
[ __ ] hits the fan until I have nowhere
though don't you feel like it was a
sudden shift in energy like well I don't
think he wants to allow himself to be
moved by what she's doing see I thought
there was a subtle I thought he caught
something and there's no lyrics I
thought that it might be yeah cuz she
she says something she specifies a john
behind her who she'll see hang or
something like that something basically
[ __ ] you wish to him after he asked her
like is there another verse yeah yeah
yeah and I like to establish chemistry
with Sam Jackson and Kurt Russell in the
sense that like you know there are two
different bounty hunters with two very
different codes yeah you know like I
like how Kurt Russell he didn't seem
like he had anything against black
people you know
right yeah until Sam Jackson you found
out Sam Jackson lied to him about it but
like will says even earlier have steak
with him at one point that weird I think
of like you don't get the sense that
John Ruth is necessarily like you know
full-out
racist per se but everyone back then was
most most people were at least a little
bit like you know probably doesn't
regard him as like an equal but there is
probably a professional respect yeah and
a respect for war service you know that
that turns that over and I love how Sam
Jackson really was a character you know
it wasn't samuel l.jackson just being
loud again yeah like it was actually
more toned-down than a lot of his like
except the students apart after you know
he's like yelling in agony but before
that he's not like mr. loud Jackson as
usual yeah yeah and I love how nasty the
character is like he is a man who's just
looking out for himself he doesn't like
that he's just looking up for himself
but there are there shades of that not
every shade but there are shades of that
that you can at least understand because
of his position in that world you know
exactly it's like this is a guy who
would have to kind of do whatever it
takes to get by to survive and you know
to subsist in this world and then
there's one particular plot point in
which he does go beyond that to the
point of like yeah that's cruel dude
like I don't think I would have done by
the end of this movie I hated Samuel
Jackson's character I created him like
there are a lot of things you can
forgive when he gets vindictive it's no
you can totally see how little he cares
about life how a little value he he
gives to other people because you know
you hear his history he killed over a
hundred people right or it was a 37 of
his side and then like 47 cops or
something sure whatever
well it's like all the all the you know
soldiers and stuff who man that prison
died in that fire well as prisoners yeah
and and I get the sense that for
just like you didn't give it find a way
out so it's not mine you know [ __ ] about
anybody and then [ __ ] help you see
that later on in the film winning is
just like killing people who left and
right if you didn't care I don't think
he doesn't care about anybody but I
think like I think no because he never
cares about would be it's it's the
respect of like who's in the room with
me now who do I have yeah rapport with
or respect like you know a professional
respect because this isn't a world that
is ever gonna give him anything you know
what I didn't see coming was like at the
end of Walter ago Watson Goggins and Sam
Jackson would be like buddies about the
whole thing you know I didn't like that
I I kind of admire it for how [ __ ]
like nasty they went with how this nasty
moment of you know especially them
delighting in this person's death is
what really bonds them in good mo but
each is yeah each is a man of his own
code yeah their codes just happen to
align for that it's like they're not
really friends per se but they both been
wronged by the same person my enemy of
my enemy is my friend you know yeah cuz
it starts off with them and you know
like he's racist and he doesn't like
black people and stuff but he's also
very friendly and starts out very really
yeah he starts out very friendly and
vulnerable and by the end of it he's I
don't know I think that he really showed
how much of a coward he was by the end
of the film coward and he and power
hungry he's power on greens an
opportunity buddy I feel like yeah
bugging us to a degree turned down the
he turned down a lot of [ __ ] money
because at the end of the day this woman
still tried to kill him
everyone well the thing is it seems like
you this is what happens when you get
everyone all these are these are sort of
junkyard dogs all in it for themselves
you know or at least who are all
watching their own backs first and
foremost and what happened with the Kurt
Russell and Sam Jackson they they would
look out for each other though you know
and I feel like until until he lied to
him and I liked that they never brought
that back around like does he broke his
trust that that bond is broke
moment though and he found out that he
lied it was so I just did I hurt your
feelings it was a matter of fashion when
you see him talking about the letter and
asking to see it the beginning he was
like you think he like turns into a
little boy yeah reading it puts the
glasses on so amused by it and then to
see the utter disappointment and
embarrassment anger when he found that
it was alive yeah I mean I could see why
he felt hurt by it because I'm sure
that's one of the things that really
made him like or at least you know have
some type of respect and Trust which was
Samuel Johnson's characters but which
was his what that Rikki's warren he he
did it for that exact reason yeah yeah
yeah and that adds more to Sam Jackson's
character of just being like man but no
I am I err that because it's it's
actually hard to write characters like
that when they're not is like it's easy
to write a character like that when
you're when they're just like you know
all they do is murder but they but this
film is is has a classic Tarantino
driven dialogue and in a less flashy way
actually and what I like about the
dialogue is that these are you're
listening to these nasty hateful eight
talk you know and you're Liz boy I
don'ts the other thing too is it's nice
to have a movie where it's like even
even even shitty people relax and share
a few laughs you know yeah so it's like
you know that's what makes it partly I'm
using to watch you know it's not just
people going yeah you know and I think I
think it's hard to write characters like
that where you're genuinely interested
in their just in their dialogue and not
just what cuz yeah it's a it's a weird
film because Tarantino kind of allows
you to choose who you root for yeah you
know that's what's right really I could
see people like Veronica was like well
at least the gang channing tatum's gang
was you know at least it was out love of
what he was trying to do because he was
trying to save his sister you know and
so that's one argument one can make
but you know then the counter argument
could be well he's still like a [ __ ]
criminal and he murdered he's the one
who led the murder of all the nice
people in the movie well you can only
imagine what you know this gang has
probably done in their spare time
yeah exactly this situation wasn't at
hand because they seem like they enjoy
doing that too yeah yeah especially
Michael Madsen you know or they had no
no question about doing it you know
because it's a sister like we're gonna
kill all these innocent people because
it's just what we do like and this is
how we get her back that's the plan
Michael Madsen though Jo gage the thing
with Michael Madsen's character I just
wanted to see him a little more I like
that they used him differently this time
because I'm so used to him coming on and
really just be getting to do it yeah
he's very serious though I think he was
one of the most mysterious characters
yeah because he was so understated and
so mellow I was like I was looking at
him more because I was like I don't know
this guy interesting he could and that
was why when you leaned over to me and
you were like who was Bob Bob poison I
was like I don't know I think it could
have been him I think it could have been
Michael Madsen oh really
yeah just because it's like something's
up with Bob Michael Madsen is so
agreeable and so it kind of doesn't want
any part of this that I don't know did
they ever even tell us who did it yeah
Bob Bob Joe gage says he did it I
thought he was just saying that cuz he
was trying to protect her I guess you
could argue that but still it was either
him or or or Tim Ross commissioned Tim
Rock I really love his character Tim
Roth brought the perfect level because
that character could have easily been
like this character doesn't belong he's
too cartoony yeah he brought it to an
authentic level and I love the energy of
the character he was he was kind of a
comic relief in some ways yeah I think
maybe
part of the reason why I was telling
Ryan earlier that I I got a sense of
comfort
um his character I think that might have
been why because he just seemed so I
don't really seem like an honorable man
I kind of wish they left him out of the
gang though to be honest I mean like he
fit in because I know I like the idea of
him being the hangman character like I I
thought that was a cooler character than
just making him one of the get one of
the people a part of the game but you
could you could further surmise that
maybe that's his role in this gang is
maybe because he is from a different
land he's British he can at least at
least go from cockney to a more affluent
dialect like perhaps he is more of the
con artist in their operation instead of
you know more muscle or you know those
gangsters are damn good actors that's
for sure
yeah Channing Tatum he's alright I mean
I wasn't blown away but it was I but
he's he does just fine because when this
in the credits when it says and Channing
Tatum I was like he's gonna be like a
really special character which he was he
was important care yeah but he wasn't
like you really need Channing quite
believe that he would be the leader of
the game I could see why someone
wouldn't buy that yeah he like he was
playing a leader
well a he looks a lot younger than
everyone else I think all these older
dudes were just following him around and
I don't know but at the same time I'm
like well he's kind of like the charming
leader of the gang you know easy speaks
French and and I mean there were outlaws
like that he's like more of the
intellectual outlaw whereas everyone
else was more just nasty ya know and
I'll see I mean you don't know how much
French he really speaks you know that's
right it's a fun it's like you know that
could be an affectation you know some
kind just to make him all the more
charming no this guy's cultured right
he's not a Rustler or bandit of any kind
I feel like with Channing Tatum's
performance I feel like the second time
I watch this movie I'm gonna get them
it's gonna be more clear to me and I
think I'm gonna like it more the second
time I watch his performance well least
me it's like going in you
or at least I almost expected like oh
he's gonna make him some kind of more
more colourful kid exactly yeah and I
feel like maybe in the next cuz this I
mean he was really subtle and he didn't
try to steal the show you know yeah
there there were like little moments
especially in that one like profile shot
when he's really he's really telling it
to Bruce Dern in front of the fire like
there are some really good little
nuances in that speech but yeah but yeah
he's not like a flashy performance or a
wild and I like how he wasn't mr. smiley
evil guy yeah you know like China tater
coulda easily result resorted to just
charm but he doesn't he keeps it pretty
authentic yeah this is I mean just
talking about it I'm like actually it's
a pretty cool performance II know in a
lot of ways I didn't recognize him at
first when he shot Sam Jackson's nuts
yeah I didn't recognize it was him it
was dark you can't see it was fast too
yeah and then he was speaking Spanish or
French for whatever I don't know is
being that's chanting tubes
introductions shooting Sam Jackson's
balls Tarantino likes to shoot the
crotch yeah something we do like I mean
for better for worse he does go places
like that yeah yeah can I just go back
to Channing Tatum really quick his face
was he had the prettiest face out of
everybody species in that movie and when
he pops up I mean you don't really see
much of him in the film and then when he
pops up out of the basement to see his
sister and they have that moment of love
and and relief of seeing each other and
they're smiling and then all of a sudden
he gets his head gets blown off yeah it
was the most like from my preference I I
didn't like the second half as much just
because I'm not crazy about violin it's
just very hard was very hard for me to
watch so when I saw some kind of inkling
of like love like relief suddenly it was
all taken away
and that was traumatized well the thing
with that scene though is like what else
would Sam Jackson do his character it's
like no it's I saw I mean I saw it
coming that he was I saw it coming this
head was gonna get blown off because I'm
like that's what his character is gonna
do to him I'm like if a guy boom my
balls off the second I see him going to
annihilate him yeah Channing Tatum
deserve to get hurt no no what not
Channing Tatum Sam tell Jackson I was
glad don't blow a guy's nuts off
he was the that was the only violence
that I was totally okay with once
impacts it was getting tortured they do
give him it's weird in the main action
of the story he is perhaps the most
agreeable character but in his he's the
one character we get a backstory scene
on yeah
and it's a pretty despicable scene yeah
I know like you you get why he's so
vindictive because it's you know it's
you were my representative of somebody I
hate the most who has done the most
wrong to me in this world but then you
know at least me as a human being I was
like this is still terrible like this do
you yeah yes Samuel Jackson I'm I'm
really glad they gave us a scene that
shows how despicable this guy can be
because it's Samuel Jackson are you
talking about when he had yeah I'm not I
don't want to worry with him raping that
guy I don't agree with that I'm saying
that the idea of dust giving us a actual
flashback was neat to me because Samuel
Jackson is the easiest one to like it
first
you know he's charming he seems nice he
seems like to be the most polite dude
well in in that society you
automatically sympathize with him
because life is tarah exactly exactly is
hard and so made sense to give out of
all the characters a flashback you're
gonna give it to him so yeah that that
just added so much weight to not liking
him because then that one scene you're
like
I don't know about you like this guy
anymore what it's further challenging
because you think to yourself like you
know a racist bastard of a general like
you know if I could get my hands on him
or you know his kid or somebody like you
know that's that's that's a revenge
fantasy yeah someone might say tell on a
battlefield you know I think that um
Tarantino intended that sort of thing
for every character because with each
one you're pretty much misled and then
so it suddenly and abruptly you see just
how despicable they are like for Kurt
Russell's character you see him just
kind of conversing with Samuel Jackson
like they're you know like he seems like
he was a pretty decent person for the
most part and then when he elbows Daisy
in the face you really see how
disgusting then you punched her before
that - yeah yeah yeah yeah but they're
holding up this like you know affable
conversation and then he'll just whack
her and you're like right you know they
don't think they're not viewing her
thinking she's simply the woman Daisy
you see this poor woman beaten
vulnerable woman but then in his fear
her the way that she's looking at Samuel
Jackson like licking her lips when she
has blood all over her face you don't
see how disgusting she is and then with
the whole gang when you see them at
first they're very charming you can see
they're friendly and lovable funny and
then all of a sudden they Massacre
entire it's like everyone is rough
everybody is from a nasty part of old
you know older Western society and
everyone has a lack of humanity
somewhere because these are you know
these are you have a bounty hunter you
know an ex-soldier you have like a
racist old general you have a gang like
everyone comes from a rough place in
society if not a bad place yes Tarantino
what I love about his films and this
film did it to where I'm watching it
and before the intermission I was I mean
during the intermission I was like where
exactly is this film you've been going
and but then you see it's going
somewhere eventually alike and I like
how Tarantino does that where you might
be watching things play out but you're
like I'm not exactly sure what's going
on I'm like you're just talking a lot of
music from the thing because yeah
because anymore Kony scored the thing
for John Carpenter and I don't think he
used much of any of it and I think he
also took one from Exorcist to Ennio
Morricone scored like I think it's like
30 or 35 minutes of new music just for
hateful eight but what he also did was
he gave Tarantino the music he made for
the thing because John Carpenter didn't
use a vast majority of it so they used
what was intended for the thing but
didn't actually get put in the movie
exactly and that's cool and there are
they're not the same kind of movie but
there are you know you got a bunch of
folks stranded in an Arctic or you know
in a frigid outpost somewhere kind of
all paranoid of one another yeah it was
great music I think neat connective
tissue between the hateful eight and the
thing you know what I really love about
this movie is how they do exactly maybe
dicks know what you talked about where
this movie like Tarantino doesn't
beautifully where he knows how to make
you go oh well here's what a typical
movie would do and he doesn't go let's
have them do the opposite but let's just
have them do something different you
know
then watch them what you'd expect is an
easy way to fool an audience can be like
let's do the opposite of what they're
thinking but then but instead of just
going for opposite he's like let's just
take this in a direction people wouldn't
even expect yeah that's very
unproductive
and like it like unveiling people like I
would have never seen them come like
coming together at the end
Sam Jackson and Walton Goggins and like
I would have never seen that coming I
would have never seen it coming that
Walton Goggins would live that far
you know until the very end yeah like
that scene where he's talking about the
money and like getting it his reasoning
for why he is not accepting the money I
completely bought because at first I'm
like well knowing the character yeah
he's probably gonna give in to the money
yeah
then he doesn't and they give perfect
reasoning out of little detail yeah
you're like you broke my truck I could
have been vomiting gallons yeah right I
am but since I'm now helpful to you like
yeah I don't necessarily buyers like his
detail the details of Tarantino's little
tiny [ __ ] things like the Abraham
Lincoln letter
you're not thinking that's gonna pay pay
me you know real importance and then it
does in the dynamics with Kurt Russell
and Sam Jackson like when Sam Jackson
sees the little ball thingy the candy or
whatever on the other they don't do like
a shot where it slowly zooms in on the
one that Sam Jackson was looking at or
something it and the same thing with
Walter Walton Goggins spilling the
coffee
it seems so casual but it's an important
part well and it's all I mean that's
that's sort of the stuff that that does
go wrong or that does giveaway it's like
he figures out the whole thing with the
stew it's like it's a little detailed
nobody would have thought of but if you
know you know yeah that's you know
usually these things come apart at least
in these movies in yeah I'm sure in
certain plans like stuff comes apart
when you overlook the details somebody
else is not going to and it's a it's
just a fun mystery like the twists and
turns I could see why someone would
really prefer the first half because the
last half it's kind of a nitpick for me
and the same time it's kind of just the
criticism for me I feel like the last
act it kind of just lost a lot of the
mystery vibe and the second one it all
comes out
yeah just turns into like massive
bloodshed then I kind of like that
because because the first half is like
setting up a whole bunch of dominoes and
then the second half comes in it goes
here is the the finger that's gonna
knock these over and it's called become
yeah so that's why I like it at the same
time
and then from there you just watch them
all fall down because you are watching
these characters for like a solid hour
and 40 minutes not being super ruthless
and then suddenly they're all like what
everywhere you know yeah they're
supposed to all kind of just be waiting
like the guys are just we're just gonna
wait this out like they blow off that
guy's head all the vomiting on the blood
like her rustling vomits on the girl at
one point yeah honestly uh the first
half of the movie I had so much fun like
from the just even running into the
theater because I guess there's no
trailers yes the movie and we didn't
know that and it was starting it was
12:15 and we were running to the theater
we get in there and it was just such a
different experience because it wasn't
like a normal film and then I was
laughing throughout the entire thing I
thought it was incredibly entertaining
but to be completely honest the second
half I probably wouldn't want to see
again just cuz it was too brutal for me
my own personal opinion I don't blame
you
that's just who I am not what I've never
I would really don't blame you because I
it's the violence in what I like movies
with violence where the violence is
effective where it's shocking in a sense
where how do I put it you know it's not
like tortured or fun in any way it's
it's shocking and it's effective and it
serves the story and it's Tarantino it's
like it's not like I wasn't expecting it
I knew it was coming
yeah more especially with this is like
Tarantino has a way of making it so that
violence still has rhythm but still
hurts like yeah you're still like ah
like like there's still style yet it's
like disturbing like when yeah when he
starts that Bob starts stabbing that guy
in the back that's like [ __ ]
disturbing that's rural and that's a you
know we have that whole thing with like
seven people in the back is like a
dishonourable wave yeah somebody like it
it's ugly
like you know it's allowed to be ugly
but then you got like fun Gore we're
like the vomiting can be funny and
sometimes she shoots
the guy's head blows up the Kaiser yeah
too much no you see like I could see why
people would say and I'm glad there's an
intermission because seriously after the
intermission it's a very different film
but it works it does make the leap there
no I wouldn't say like a slow transition
it's like it makes the leap to that next
type of genre that this film is yeah
that was so cool it was such a different
fun movie it was an experience yeah
Tarantino set out to give you an
experience that wasn't what a lot of
directors today wouldn't do which is hey
we're gonna throw an intermission in
there got an overture [ __ ] the trailers
yeah I'm gonna narrate parts over it is
you know making it an event to go to the
theater and experience a movie again you
know yeah I have to say though the
narration kind of pulled me out of it a
little bit I didn't feel like I mean
whose voice was up I thought I couldn't
shut those Tarantino or Steve Buscemi I
mean usually does some kind of cameo in
his movie I'm pretty sure I'm pretty
sure that was Tarantino there's certain
ways he spoke that that sounded
Tarantino yeah what's he come looking at
it on IMDB right now it wasn't yeah okay
good job good job Jay I'm proud of you
I'm proud of you and yeah I like how
Tarantino knows in this world that race
plays a big part you know like that
little detail of why me me wouldn't let
Bob work here mini mini me me my mini
wouldn't let Bob work there because he's
Mexican yeah you know I'm like yeah at
that time there's this racist world
people really define themselves like
they would look at people by their race
and it's funny the revenant does that
from the frontiers and yeah yeah exactly
so that having that detail I'm like yeah
I totally buy that
I believe that could happen and yeah and
you know it man this movie is it's
pretty [ __ ] awesome I think the
movies awesome all the characters are
interesting yes it's caught I'm just
saying it's called hateful eight and if
it held back I would have [ __ ] hated
it well and going back to that thing you
said before you like taking things and
and not necessarily doing the opposites
but doing something different with
certain plot points I feel like that is
a fundamental Tarantino thing where it's
like a lot of movies
today we focus on the plot and it's like
okay what can we do different with the
plot whereas I feel like Tarantino comes
from at the other side and goes what
choice would this character exactly yeah
because that's what all of his like part
of the reason people love is dialogue so
much is because it's character
development but it's character
development by going okay what would
these two guys I know who these people
well they don't talk about what would
they react to yeah what would they
notice and then yeah you know how these
plots unfold because every story in life
comes out of people reacting the way
they would react not because of a
predetermined plot exactly credibly
original and unique totally totally yeah
and it is I could see why people were
saying it's Reservoir Dogs similarities
because yeah I rarely takes place in one
location though yeah there's blood
starts killing the thing has yet to go
down roars and Reservoir Dogs that went
down off screen before yeah and I like
what with Tim Roth I'm glad he's back in
a Tarantino film cuz he hasn't done
anything with him since Pulp Fiction I
thought he was so great yeah it was like
back in the 90s when he worked with
Tarantino last yeah and he started off
with Tarantino Reservoir Dogs so to see
him back and then to but I love about
Tim Roth in every [ __ ] Tarantino film
he's a different character totally
different you know Sam Jackson kind of
has his thing
even even when he's playing olds Sam
Jackson who's serving DiCaprio who you
know like even there's like the Sam
Jackson touches Tim Roth is always like
totally different and I think that's
cool that
he uses that kind of character actor
Tarantino to his effect you know because
he usually brings people in to be like I
hear their voice doing it
Tim Rafi brings him into like really
change up the character yeah yeah like I
really it's kind of like how you know
Scorsese has his DiCaprio now and how
does DeNiro well this seems like
Tarantino has a sort of what do you call
that like a troupe of people he likes to
work with but he'll kind of put them all
the right places like it doesn't seem
like he'll shoehorn yeah exactly it's
like Tim Roth was the guy to play that
to play that character you know you
could have put Christoph Waltz
everybody's not that really saw
Christoph Waltz playing that as well but
I was glad that it was Tim Roth I mean
he just recently watched Reservoir Dogs
so um it was cool to see his face and
but but you could really see how much
time is tough since his first movie yeah
if I sing had Tim Roth has aged oh was
it gonna say I had a really good point
it was such a strong point that you guys
were gonna freak out over and be like
yes I'm glad you addressed that but I
can't remember at all what it was um how
did you feel about the ending I mean I
thought I didn't it kind of right where
I was supposed to cuz that's the thing
too is like you can this is the kind of
movie you can be okay with cuz everybody
dies everybody dies because everyone's a
shitty person who for some reason yeah I
know it's about the way people die yeah
exactly
exactly now I would have liked a
different outcome honestly I thought it
was kind of cool that they hope with you
I would have liked if they if they had
got Daisy out of that and the gang one
is still very shitty people like how
would hate of that actually know exactly
what I wanted the girl to win yeah I
brought I'll probably get some hate from
from the subscribers about that but know
whatever
and know what my opinion mhmmm know and
I know that's the thing is he there's
other people out there we're gonna want
other people to win ya know so that's
one for a moment there I thought it it
was at least possible it could go that
way yeah it's like oh [ __ ] you know he's
listening now this could go that way the
reason why I thought that it was strange
that he decided not to go with a deal is
because I honestly believed her that
there was 15 other gang members in the
city it doesn't matter if she's dead
he's dead well it's that it's that thing
of like we don't know and that's kind of
how well you it's how you react her it's
like you could easily go I think she's
lying too or I think she's telling the
truth but to him I think it just
ultimately doesn't matter cuz it's
because he recognizes that she's just
taking the opportunity yeah I'm going
you are my only Ally left in the room
and I can spin this this movies like
what I would have let you stand there
and vomit up torrents of blood a minute
ago so that we have no no rapport here
we can't blame her though I loved her
facial expression when he mentioned that
she just seemed like it was like duh why
would I why would I try to save anybody
here right now I don't give a [ __ ] about
anybody just like you don't give a [ __ ]
about anybody but that's a very tenuous
threat like that that's a very you can't
necessarily count on somebody to go well
yeah yeah this view is awesome so
different oh can we talk about um can we
talk about Bob haha Demian Bichir I knew
I know you didn't laugh as much but I
did he was so much fun he had so much
personality it's such a kind of relaxed
way about him the one Mexican character
yeah because you never see Mexican or
let Latino people in timepieces like
that especially westerns do yeah will
you do you did you did know did in in
older West but not as not as such a like
what no not a character like that yeah
less vocally there and in Grange I
haven't seen a million westerns but a
lot of the Mexicans you
you're like kind of the way they treat
Indians maybe a little more civilized or
Native Americans as you'd say but you
know like kind of more civilized but
still like they're not the people we
want to be dealing with a whole lot or
maybe they're a sidekick of some kind
but yeah you don't see this game loved
him you know yeah yeah I'll hug each
other before like the mission begins
like they are okay I like that moment
where the gang hugs each other because
they're like we've all might die like
this is a risky mission this is
something you do have to give this like
you know there are a multicultural Bunch
ya know there's a there's a cockney guy
a Mexican guy a woman there's you know
yeah yeah that's true pretty boy pretty
boy and you don't know who else might
have been in the gang before and Michael
Madsen you know the creepy quiet guy I
gotta say Oh nan Zoe Bell I think huh I
think she's evolved as an actress she's
ghost like a little girl cousin desktop
bounce she's she's the New Zealand chick
and well hold on one second one second
okay you don't remember death Proof
I saw death Proof and I remember not
knowing the fact that she's really a
stunt woman that's what makes it so cool
that she's in the movie and stuff I
thought she was just an actress yeah who
like did her instance at one point yeah
so I again I didn't really like her
acting in that film yeah I didn't really
like her acting in that film I know I
was very aware that like once I heard
she was a first-time actor so I was like
now that makes sense but watching this I
was like she seems like she's become a
lot more natural and a lot more
comfortable saying actual dialogue so it
was cool to see that like I can see what
Tarantino still keeps you around yeah
because you're just down to get better
yeah one it brings something like she is
the most cheerful character yeah which
is just a nice break
yeah from so much dour and it also then
makes her fate that much more upsetting
but like but you know it's nice to have
a little ray of sunshine for a second
there like Tarantino really has fun with
his audience
totally he loves to [ __ ] with us and I I
liked there's a couple of touches that I
did like that he added too you know
normally in films with someone gets shot
in the crotch that's the end of that
character he let that be something that
plays out with Sam Jackson well again
I'm not an expert but imagine a lot of
things that happen back then you would
just bleed out for a long time yeah
exactly you know you would you would
sustain a wound and then you would just
sort of especially you know trapped like
that we're gonna be here awhile yeah and
the bleeding out thing is kind of
similar to like Tim Roth in Reservoir
Dogs anything out the whole time
yeah so having that touch of Sam Jackson
you know having his balls blown off but
like you know I respect him for like
going all out like that with a character
like that scene when he rapes the guy
immediately it's like I don't think I
like this guy he's like yeah oh that's
especially cruel yeah like I in theory I
I get the idea but you don't actually do
yeah because I was like I think guess
why I would be this upset but know this
guy you know Sam Jackson's character
might have been a you know former slave
for all we know and he was someone who
was probably tortured and ridiculed by
people like him he didn't mention the
plantation yeah probably grew up a slave
and then you know he was a slaves were
[ __ ] not treated well you know so in
theory he has every reason to hate
especially because that guy's son like i
he i has every reason to hate and not
view this guy as a human being because
nobody viewed because he probably didn't
view him as a human being he's just a
bounty price but when you see and hear
the account you're so like cruelty is
cool yeah very very mean-spirited yeah
yeah yeah absolutely
now like you wanted this to hurt I know
but then he gets his balls blown off and
then it's like that's him the whole
finale and I like how Sam Jackson was
just really committed to every second of
it you know like he was not trying to be
likable he was breeding it's not I like
seeing Sam Jackson to disappear into a
role again he's not trying to be
likeable or despicable he's just being
that
like he's being that character man these
performances are so natural that it's
like someone there deserves a [ __ ]
Oscar nomination but you really can't
decide yeah exactly
this is a movie for which you wish cuz
like I think SAG has like an ensemble
award and this is a movie you wish the
Oscars of the Golden Globes yeah cuz
you're like all these parts like this
movie moves because of these parts yeah
you know Dan this would be an awesome
[ __ ] play like I can't help but think
that I really can't this has some play
like it's one location the whole time
and the the idea and like I think a lot
of Tarantino stuff could it could be
Reservoir Dogs I heard was actually
heard there was a play dumb for
Reservoir Dogs and there's all girls
that's cool cool that'd be cool to watch
huh yeah let me tell you what like a
virgin's yeah I mean is that like pretty
much what you think oh yeah yeah we
should talk about ography I was thinking
that too when I was watching it like
damn is some beautiful cinematography
and it's not as wild as some of the old
some of the other Tarantino movies get
with the kit like there aren't a lot of
those like whip zooms and things like
that lash title text you know like it's
the least cuz even inglorious basterds
has like a 70s exploit a totally sure
loo with the random Sam Jackson
narrations and stuff yeah and Django is
is more straight than than inglorious
bastards in some ways but it's still
there are a lot of pop music cues a lot
of color to that mystic yeah whereas
this is the most sort of stark of them
and the camera like you know the way
they shot it is is gorgeous but it's
also refined and then they did these
things with these like split diopter
shots that you would have seen back then
yeah and it's a little more like doing
it because that's what they would have
done yeah yeah like director 10 like
there's the there's the shot where
Walton Goggins is holding the gun
against Michael mattes
and Tim Roth and then you know Sam
Jackson's like refilling his his bullets
and stuff and I like I love that shot
it's kind of like Brian DePalma
reminisce and actually to me a little
bit yeah and I know he was a big fan of
Brian DePalma growing up too so I feel
like that there could be that touch for
sure and watching
I was rewatching a lot of Tarantino
films me he really has evolved a lot as
a director you know like in like with
the editing style - I know you know he
didn't edit the film but the editing
style of this film is like you can
always tell that he works like would the
editors got an editor he trusts and who
yeah and I like how this film I think
this is like the most cuts I've seen him
do since like Kill Bill Vol 1 because he
he normally lets the camera just really
go on you know and let it and sometimes
it's just a master shot if this is the
the actors just performing yeah this
film I noticed he does mess with angles
a little bit more and not in a flashy
way like I didn't feel like I was
watching Tarantino film this time around
yeah I felt like I was just watching a
[ __ ] film you know when I feel like
that that almost makes it more thrilling
is like you're you're confined to one
space and it's not very big sort of if
we can play with focal lengths and how
frequently we're cutting and what we're
cutting - yeah you know and also just
like if some characters talking there
are times where they'll cut away to a
different character for a while doing
stuff so you really get the sense for
the room and it makes it a little more
thrilling you know yes it makes the room
feel a little more claustrophobic you
know yeah yeah and before we're done I
want to mention Bruce Dern yeah even him
it's like at first I was like these
characters are kind of OneNote and then
I thought about it immediately after I
said that to myself and I was like
aren't people who are gonna give you a
lot up front yeah they were all very
defined yeah they were they were all
very defined in and I like what they did
with I love that turn you know you don't
see it coming like general the general
is talking about his son at one
right and you just don't see that coming
with what Sam Jackson talks about but
the setup to that where he walks over to
him gives him a bolus what was it soup
what else to do and then he was he was
like I shared the battlefield with this
guy you know can I sit down but he just
wants to sit there to taunt him give my
gun so he could shoot you know like and
I like how they established that earlier
too like you can't shoot an old guy no
he's unarmed you can't shoot someone
unarmed yeah and then he finds a way to
make the guy pick up the gun to shoot
that makes you wonder if that story is
actually true because it's such exactly
ticularly exactly it's so and also like
putting your dick in somebody's mouth is
not again I don't know but I don't think
that was a common thing you would just
cop to in a room back then yeah I know
cuz though yeah it was kind of shot my
oranges down with homosexual behavior it
was kind of shot like a fantasy too yeah
you know it was kind of shot like maybe
that's why he cut to that maybe not as a
flashback but he was just showing like
some imagination because he says to him
you're starting to get pictures huh
remember I said that's I'm like that's
great line you know like totally [ __ ]
with this guy and I remember the
intermission hit I was like I don't
think he actually did that but they
don't ever establish whether or not he
actually did it or not yeah wasn't a
react well he shoots them and then it
cuts intermission and then when we come
back everybody's all chill that's how it
would have been and then they touch on
that too they're like you know it's in
the narration they're like self-defense
I'm een like it's it's pretty
cut-and-dry like he reached for the gun
and he shot him to defend himself yeah
you're living at nobody in that room has
a tied to that character yeah the one
character has no allegiance to anybody
yeah smart very smart you really was was
life remotely like that though where
people just probably
each other we're but the but justice is
a lot more gray back then because you
don't have surveillance all you have to
go on is the word of a few people right
yeah and everyone's packing yeah exactly
exactly and they even go over that thing
about injustice versus mob Chester
frontier just yeah yeah you know justice
was less systematic at least back then
you know there are there are places you
can hide from the law back and if a
bunch of people are in an isolated space
I can imagine that they would be like
well we all saw there's no reason to
take this any further especially if
they're all kind of shitty people huh
yeah I [ __ ] and Jamie and Obie - like
he meant Oh Oh be poor open yeah Obie
was like the one guy buddy like your
good drivers you got a cool hat never
wanted anything bad happens yeah spec
full he's respectful he [ __ ] went
outside dead to do the necessary moment
he comes back in the pits yeah yeah I'm
really I'm really a married I'm really
impressed you know I said earlier saw
one of my favorite Tarantino films but I
feel like it's climbing the list
it could be I've heard I've heard a few
people say that it's their favorite this
pulp fiction yeah it's totally climbing
the list you know it's it seems to be
just just from the few like sort of top
10 as I've seen her top aides of
Tarantino films it's for a lot of people
I know it's hovering in the middle to
the kind of number four area yeah yeah I
think it was definitely a most
entertaining that I've watched yeah and
it's the most straightforward you know
yeah it's the most yeah it's most
different out of his films lately yeah
it's much different so character driven
you know it's not sit not to say a real
fast sorry not to say that his souls are
not character driven I'm saying like
this only like practically relies on
character for everything in the film
what's orchestration it's like
you know it's so different because it's
it's not simple per se yeah this is all
the complicated stuff is in trust and in
character notes and it's you know it's
it's all in one place yeah it's all one
situation and it's all one fundamental
kind of idea I love this movie anyway
guys listen we got to wrap this up
thanks for tuning in to our spoiler talk
anything else anyone one mention quite
so much just dis discussion yeah cuz you
get them every now and again but you you
don't get them a ton you know yeah yeah
Hollywood
Oh totally dude intention is one of the
few people who they like get away with
that yeah like I like you know it's like
a like Marvel movies but there's not
like a there's not like a rich well of
discussion Captain America's a good guy
the only discussion that really comes
from that is like marble and stuff is
like comparison comparisons of the
comics and [ __ ] yeah yeah it's like you
know I I enjoy when a big when a movie
of this guy it's like Tarantino's on the
few and you could argue Christopher
Nolan in a way there there are a few of
these guys but I think Tarantino
especially were you they'll give you
something that you can chew on and you
might have different reactions to
absolutely and that has sort of a
certain level of craft you know it's
like everyone can recognize its crafting
but the content you know people can
debate absolutely that's a nice thing
yeah yeah it was exciting exciting yeah
and you can feel the energy in the in
the theater two people were excited
about and you see a penis and you see
penis which which happened a lot more
than 70s which that was kind of a 70s
thing because I was watching an old
Richard Harris movie and there's there's
a moment where he's captured by a bunch
of natives and and you know he's like
bathing in a river and they're chasing
him around on their horses and stuff
like that he's just naked and they
capture him and like they you know take
him back to their village like and it
was a thing you would see more people
wouldn't be as well it's a dick
like in the 70s oh yeah that poor actor
yeah that must have been a shitty day on
set for that act that poor actor we're
like we're gonna hire you
you're gonna be naked yeah we're gonna
show your genitals then you gotta suck
Samuel Jackson's dick
Craig stark in the snow Craig start cuz
his name poor guy I was thinking that I
was thinking like I wonder how
embarrassing that was to show that to
his friends and family that you know
many people are gonna see Scotland's
most respected actor not just him be
naked but sucking Samuel that
performance required nothing but being
degraded one I mean granted they're both
in a shitty situation but those are two
things that we don't kind of ever
acknowledge is like male-on-male sexual
assault of any kind unless we're joking
about it in a prison comedy and just
dudes being naked as a weird thing for
people in movies yeah you know that is
slowly starting to change but you know
it's just interesting that I think these
films need more penis at least an equal
amount equal we mean equal to I think
every two tits we see a penis that's
that was actually the ruled that the
Duplass brothers imposed on their HBO
show they're like for repair boobs we
will show a dick what you know keep
things balanced that's and that's the
girl in Game of Thrones what's her name
uh the one who plays Daenerys Targaryen
like her there should be I think she
said this she was like actresses get
naked on the show all the time there
should be or I think John Kit Harington
plays Jon Snow also echoed this was like
there should be more male nudity it
should just be if this is the thing
we're gonna accept happens like
everybody got naked and we should just
show everybody because that's not fair
like that's cool I'm gonna show my penis
so like this movie has nudity but it's
only frontal male nudity and how do I
get a bigger penis
I will pump my penis before we film
these reactions are going to change
listen guys for you to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects Jerry
reasons to GRE dank ass dubs on this
channel
Veronica success has her own channel
it's primarily
epic movie reviews no it's not guys
music and video it's music channel music
and kind of travel vlog channel yeah and
if you're Jewish you'll love it you'll
love it
I actually I'll throw this in there
I actually documented meeting Tyrone
Magnus in the last couple of blogs that
I did you guys want to see behind the
scenes with Ryan and Tyrone
check out my love's I thought you're
gonna say I met a Jew and I got it on
camera for the first time that's
terrible I thought that's where you're
gonna say cause I was talking about how
it's good for a Jewish audience oh yeah
yeah I just want to bring that back take
care of guys bye dears